let me introduce lars and let me
introduce our new theme for this game
because everybody is excited
it's time to play what does lars like
better now here's your host howard stern
wow thank you thank you ladies and
gentlemen jose is standing by
who thinks he knows lars because he's
the head of the heavy metal channels for
20 years here at siriusxm and says he's
a metallica expert
and joe is on the phone lars who is a
big [ __ ] tool who had the balls to
call me up and
and argue with me about john bonzo
bonham's drums
and we got into an argument lars would
say without thinking
that john bonzo bonham was the number
one drummer of all time no
how much you want to bet i'll bet you
100 bucks i probably could get an answer
by tomorrow
i think it's a new game show what will
lars say
and i said lars is the expert
let's find out what lars thinks and so a
game was born
gary is going to take over the hosting
so i can play gary
all right so we asked laura's a series
of questions last night just
like 12 hours ago and i'm going to give
you two choices so we're going to start
with a really simple one
what is lars's favorite animal a dog
or a cat okay oh i know you know this
coward oh [ __ ] i know you all right
i'm i'm getting nervous because laura
says i know this and i'm like i don't
[ __ ] know this
howard doesn't know i don't know what do
you think the answer is robin
i'm gonna say because lars is so manly
that he's a dog man
he's a dog man okay jose what do you say
i'm going to go with lars is a
cat dude hmm all right joe you've proven
you don't know [ __ ] about lars
what do you say exactly yeah i'm going
to go with jose
i'm going to say same you're going to
say cat
all right all right i'm gonna say
because i love them both but
but but lars he's so masculine with that
drumming
uh and yet but lars is very
sophisticated
i'm gonna go with cat lars please give
us the answer
okay and the answer drum roll please
is a cat yes
yes and uh in this household
just on the other side of this door
actually there we have four cats
all rescue cats of course no dogs
no dogs no no dogs oh my god
getting back to the game the score is
howard won jose one joe the caller one
robin zero do something about that with
no points
all right here's one that i think
everybody wants to know
what is lars's favorite condiment is it
mustard or ketchup
trojan this is a hard one i'm gonna go
to joe
first go ahead joe i'm gonna go with
mustard because he's a dane
because he's danish you think that
you know i like that i don't know what
it means but i like that
i agree with joe in a weird way because
he's danish
i'm going i'm calling mustard as well i
i like i like the whole sound of that i
i'll say mustard um
let's go to robin i'm saying mustard
mustard popped into my head immediately
because
i think ketchup is so american i think
ketchup is disgusting and so will
lars will think like me uh jose go ahead
you're a metal guy
you you claim you're certainly pumped up
you're maybe too much so thank you
can you share have you ever shared with
howard and robin the uh the pump
up thing you do right before you get
going i just do a vocal warm-up
and i impersonate metallica's james
hetfield
so i do a lot of that stuff i hope i
didn't embarrass you
no dude i love that i'm proud of that
all right jose go ahead
let's see if you have any kind of common
sense i'm gonna go with
mustard but i'm gonna go with the brown
spicy mustard like the grey poupon man i
feel like lars is more of a fancy
dude where he sticks his knife his
butter knife into the
jarred mustard and then and then like
smears it on stuff so i'm going to say
he's a gray poupon spicy mustard guy
lars please the answer the answer is uh
everybody's right
wow what about the group i'm on the
board
and you know i think we're gonna have to
uh we're gonna have to give extra props
here to jose because uh
i am more of a uh of a knife kind of
gray
pawn kind of yes
[Applause]
i like i like the mustard with a little
bit of a little bit of kick to it
okay we'll get a little uh more
interesting here we asked lars who is
favorite
superhero was oh good did he say green
lantern
or the flash green
the flash does one thing he does it well
i'm gonna go with flash based on the
fact that flash does one thing
and he focuses on it and that kind of is
a lars way of life
that's my vote uh go ahead robin i don't
even think
lars knew there was a green lantern
because he's not a douche
all right uh robin says flash um
let's go to mr expert who for some
reason warms up like he's james
uh jose go ahead
lars is gonna say the flash man his
double bass
drumming the flash uh the speed yes yes
uh
joe go ahead i'm going flash same
same okay what is your answer you guys
are all on it
on it on it the flash absolutely all
right
one last question because right now
we're all tied up some robin's down one
point
right there's a three-way tie gary go
ahead
okay we asked lars who was his favorite
comedian
oh and did he say bobcat gold weight or
sandwich innocent
oh
now i'm gonna tell you i'll go first
bobcat was extremely close
to kirk to uh kurt cobain yeah so
i could see bobcat and lars
being incredibly close bonding
but sam kinnison who was a dear friend
of mine
loved musicians sam kinnison was maybe
the most brilliant comedian i had ever
heard i'm going with sam kinnison i
don't care because
it's just got to be okay i'm kennison
robin go ahead
i'm going with kennison you're going
with kennison
look at jose beaming over there like he
knows something he knows
the first thing that came into my metal
soul
is sam kinnison all right let's go to
joe
same kid and don't forget nobody's
winning this game
if we've got a true
all right let's lock it in let's get the
drum roll and let's turn to the man of
the hour
i'll tell you what uh let's hang this
just hold hold
stop the drums don't stop the drum roll
let me just say that and yes howard
you're you're totally right about bobcat
obviously
bobcat would play san francisco i'm
talking 84 and 85
and james and i would go see him he
loved music we love
comedy obviously especially cutting edge
stuff and bobcat
was great this was the time when he was
doing
mostly just the screaming character uh
kennison was about a year
later his comedy was so intellectual and
was so smart
those first three or four years insane
so if we have the drum roll from
you can probably guess where this is
going
there it is the drum roll and larsa's
favorite comedian
is sam kinnison and gets a 100 again
why isn't that great this game can go
listen this game
we can do this forever you just keep
answering questions yes lars thanks for
doing this from everyone at the game
what does lars think
uh we say a dude thanks lars thank you
mars gary it's great to see you guys
thank you
love you much love san francisco and um
hopefully we'll catch up soon